- [Announcer] How much would
$300,000 change your life?
- What the (beep).
- [Announcer] How far would you go
for a chance to win it all?
- Wow.
- [Announcer] 10 Strangers
have agreed to live
in this facility.
- It's so small.
- [Announcer] Isolated into
separate cells for 10 days.
- This is tinier than I thought.
- [Announcer] They will share
a pool of money to survive.
- A bottle of water-
- [Announcer] And whatever they
don't spend, they take home.
This is Money Game.
(orchestral music)
- My name is Rekstizzy.
I'm participant number two.
I'm a rapper and a streamer on Twitch.
This is crazy.
Yo, this shit is crazy.
I say you either love me or hate me.
I'm doing Money Game because
it seem like good time.
I'm willing to risk at all.
I might have to deceive, I'm
might have to become a scammer
and I'm trying to make some money.
Oh, come on.
Oh, no, this shit is tiny as hell.
- My name is Chantel Nicole.
I'm participant number one.
And by day I'm an ESL teacher,
but by night I'm a recording
artist, dancer, podcast, host,
and multihyphenate creator.
I believe I'm a bit of generous
and a bit of stingy
depending on the situation.
So if it does turn into me,
throwing someone under the bus
and then driving the bus over
them, I guess I'll do it.
I am participating in Money Game
for a multitude of reasons.
Like most people, I do have
student debt for college
that I can't even...
Yeah, I can't even use a degree.
It's very hard to find
work in the music industry,
even as like an assistant.
And I'd like to stop
being a lump of potato
in my mother's house.
I mean a sweet a potato,
but a potato nonetheless.
(orchestral music)
Oh my God. Okay.
- This is a lot smaller
than I thought it would be.
Oh my gosh.
My name's Dominic and
I'm a content creator.
Oh my gosh.
I dunno if I can even fit a bed.
So one of the biggest barriers
that I face in Money Game
is not necessarily going
without my phone for 10 days
or struggling to eat the
meals that I wanna eat.
It's really just being
confined in a small space.
I suffer from severe claustrophobia.
I haven't been in an elevator in 10 years,
and this is something that I'm
really going to struggle with
in this game.
- I'm gonna miss you heels.
My name is Victoria.
I'm doing Money Game
because I thought this
would be a great way
to pay off my student loans
and pay for my wedding.
I believe if you have
a powerful enough why,
you can accomplish almost any how.
Goodbye cute clothes and probable dignity.
And I'm willing to go as far
as it takes to win Money Game.
- There's just no reason it
needs to look this decrepit.
I don't know what's going on. Okay.
- [Announcer] The eight
participants are now
in their individual cells
inside the facility.
They must read the rule
book to see what it takes
to win the cash prize.
- Okay. Money Game rules.
Upon arrival,
participants must remove all
possessions and clothing,
except for undergarments.
So I'm doing Money Game for
my little brother and I.
We're both upcoming South Asian artists
and I really want to just give us a chance
to pursue the arts.
- Winners receive a grand
prize starting at $300,000.
- Okay.
To be split equally among
the remaining participants
in the social experiment.
- Participants must stay in the facility
up to 10 consecutive days.
- (knocks) How are you doing?
- What's that?
- [Kira] I asked how you're doing.
- Oh.
- You're doing all right?
- Yeah, I was thinking at
most, I would maybe get a book.
- That's what I was thinking.
- [AJ] Yeah. Okay.
- You know what we could do?
You could like trade off with people.
- Yeah, I was thinking of
could definitely do like
a little book club.
- My name is Kira. I work as a barista.
I'm a student and I'm a musician.
I'm doing Money Game
because the opportunity
to possibly win a large amount
of money is kind of too hard
to pass up.
For me being somebody that
pays rent, being a student,
and working full time
can be really difficult.
And I just wanna be able
to enjoy living my life
without having to worry
about finances for a bit.
- Hi, Number One.
- [Chantel] Hmm?
- Said, hi, Number One.
- Oh, hello Three. How are you?
- How am I?
- Yes.
- I'm as well as I can be.
- [Chantel] The starter. Oh no.
- How are you?
- I'm a little too excited, but I'm good.
Are you standing at the corner?
- Yeah, the light never turns off.
So I'm sleeping behind the curtain.
- Okay.
- My name is Sam.
I'm doing Money Game because I need money.
I have a dog named Abby who is blind
and she needs surgery for $8,000.
- Participants will use an
Intercom system to order items
from the outside world,
but with a multiplier of
100 times the normal price.
What?
Which will be deducted from
the 300,000 at the time.
- I'd like to order a vape.
Puff bar looking things.
- And how much is a pillow?
- All right, so can I
please have baby wipes
and a sleeping bag and a pillow?
A bag of almonds, a bag of
apples, and beef jerky, please.
- I need the thick boys.
I need that tonight.
- [Man] The vape will cost $2,000.
- What? It's a vape though.
Yeah, sure. But can I get water as well?
Not be able to vape is really killing me.
Like I'm really addicted to vaping.
Like usually when I'm home,
I hit it like once every five minutes.
- Oh my God. Dude, the
fricking porta potty is 2,000.
- 2,000?
- Yeah. I'm like, no thanks.
I'm gonna make it work.
- Yeah, I know. I'm okay.
- Biohazard bags must be used
to dispose of human waste
and liquids.
Toilets are available for purchase
with the participant's discretion,
but we have biohazard bags
that we can take out every day,
so why would you need one?
Defecating and urinating anywhere
but into the biohazard bags
up your toilet facilities
is strictly prohibited.
Well, damn, that foils all
my plans for this game.
- Oh my God.
It's just tight as hell.
Who did this?
(monitor beeps)
(alarm rings)
(orchestral music)
- Thanks.
- Oh.
- Yeah. Boy.
- Woof. This is awfully difficult.
- Oh, this is gonna be fun.
- Hello?
- Who's that?
- Can you hear this?
- I mean, I can't really help it,
I would love it if you could
be like completely silent.
(Rekstizzy laughs)
- Are you a light sleeper
or a heavy sleeper?
- Oh, I'm a real light sleeper.
I'm a little concerned about snoring.
- I snore.
- If you snore so loudly
that it wakes me up,
I might start pounding on the wall.
I'm just warning you now.
(Dominic knocks)
- Someone knocking?
- [Dominic] Who's that? Who's next to me?
- Oh. What's up? This is Number Six.
- So why are you here?
- I was homeless for like
three and a half years
and I just got off the streets in August
and I heard about this and I was like,
"Well, this...
If I win some money,
then would make sure I'm
never homeless again.
I was homeless.
I got into two bad car accidents
and it sent me on this
mental health spiral.
I was out of work for about
two months with no income
and newly depleted savings.
- I can't even imagine
what you're going through.
- It's almost like a bottomless pit.
It's like once you fall in,
it's near impossible to get out.
And it just got worse and worse
and it's harder to find a
job and you don't even know
where you're gonna be sleeping at night.
So then it was just a lot
sleeping on the trains
and the buses and the alleys and stuff.
Yeah, it was pretty terrible.
- Have you ordered anything yet?
- I ordered nicotine.
- Oh, all right.
I'm gonna do tens MREs. Do
you know what those are?
- Yeah. The army supply?
- Yeah. Yeah. Meals ready to
eat them in the containers.
- You're gonna get 10 of them?
- I mean, no judgment,
but it's like I promise you 10 MREs
is not gonna be costing
extra in comparison to that.
Participant number two got
nicotine right out the gate.
And his answer to me when
I asked him about it was,
"If I don't get this, I'll go crazy."
My thing is, we're all
going crazy, my dude.
- Honestly, I like to challenge myself,
but the claustrophobia is like
my biggest fear of all time.
- Oh, damn.
- So my thought process is,
if I leave, it doesn't take
away from anyone's money
and it technically leaves
more money that I don't spend.
- Oh yeah.
- [Dominic] I'd rather have
someone like you win than me.
- Okay. Do this.
- Well, I think it's time.
- Yeah, you gotta do what's
in your gut too, right?
- No, I definitely, yeah.
I expect you to win this.
Phone number re, I'm ready
to leave. Tell the producers.
(orchestral music)
I quit Money Game because
I was definitely surprised
how small the room was.
And I definitely know that
my anxiety was kicking in
and it was kind of
instinctively telling me like,
"Okay, this is gonna be tough."
So my anxiety was definitely
a contributing factor
to my decision.
And I think that I
definitely do not deserve it
over other people that were there.
(Rekstizzy snoring)
(wall bangs)
- Participant four was super annoying.
And she kept banging
on the wall every time
that Rek was snoring.
And that would wake me up.
(Rekstizzy snoring)
(wall bangs)
- Yes. Hello. I'd like a set of earplugs.
Thank you.
(monitor beeps)
- Let the 10th annual purge begin.
- Yay!
- I'm Number Six.
- Number Six. Nice to meet you.
- Hi, nice to meet you.
- Howdy? How's it going?
- Hi, nice to meet you Number Seven.
- AJ. Nice to meet you.
- AJ.
- It's Five. Nice to meet you.
- Last night I so overwhelmed.
- Been dying to get outta that room.
- Okay. How much did the screen cost?
- Like I was not expecting this at all.
- What's up, how you doing?
- Good.
- What's the going.
- Hey, how are you?
- Rek.
- Rek?
- Yeah.
- I'm Chance.
- Chance.
- Kira.
- Kira. Nice to meet you.
- Good morning y'all. Nice to meet you.
AJ, nice to meet you. Rek?
- Yeah, yeah.
- I saw you.
- Did you guys cop the bio hot?
- The bags?
- No, no, no. The toilet-
- I've been peeing standing up.
- Yeah. I'm not gonna get a toilet.
- Bag of urine. Excuse me.
(All laughing)
- What? What is that?
We're using biohazard
bags to go into bathroom.
We do have the option for the toilet,
but the toilet is way
too expensive right now.
So it's really convenient.
We just have to tie it up and you know,
just put it in the corner.
So I'm not too uncomfortable with that.
Morning.
- Morning.
(group chattering)
- By the way, this is us.
Number Eight went home.
- What?
- Oh, yo, what?
- Why?
- Get outta here.
Yeah.
- With participant eight quitting,
when I told him about, you
know, my journey in my life,
what I hope to accomplish with this game,
he was very encouraging and
made me super emotional.
- Was he (indistinct)
- Oh, it's claustrophobic.
So like was...
Yeah. And just really didn't like...
The room is smaller than
I thought it was gonna be.
- Was that the guy that
you were talking to?
- Yes.
- He sounded so like excited.
- Maybe that's why he was so talkative to
'cause he was like claustrophobic.
- I think so. Yeah.
- After participant eight quit,
I was very relieved that it happened
because it's one more
person out of the game.
- Me and her are raising a kid now like
'cause like I'm snoring.
And then whenever I snore,
she like wakes me up.
- You were snoring all night.
Let me tell you, you did not wake up.
Oh yeah.
- So she's not...
- I'm not denying it.
You know, it's a problem,
but you know, we live in a society.
(All laughing)
- I've gotten maybe two
to three hours of sleep
because of Rek.
So to the extent that I'm
really running on empty,
that's pretty annoying.
- We all have like things that,
you know, like we wanna get,
like judgment free from
everyone else, you know?
- I agree. Yeah.
- What are you hiding?
(All laughing)
- I smoke. I vape. So you
know, I'll do one a cop.
- I miss my wine, but
I'm here for the money.
So it's like, I'm just gonna
suffer for nine more days
and walk away with more.
I don't know.
- All right.
- We're getting super cozy.
- Oh, this is a bougie sleeping bed.
- Yeah.
(Suspenseful music)
- Oh, why'd you have to do that now?
(upbeat music)
- Oh, that's not so bad.
(All applauding)
- That's actually really pretty good.
- How much did we spend?
- 16,230. 16.
- 16.
- Yeah.
- Oh, better.
(group chattering)
- That's really good.
- For eight people, that's pretty good.
- Yeah, that's pretty damn good.
- Ideally, like how much do you think
we wanna walk out with?
- My personal goal is to get
outta here with at least 10K
because I have a dog who's blind
and it's my fault she has diabetes.
Like feeding her whole
life and she's only six
and her surgery is 7K I
think, something like that.
- Oh, yeah. I'm missing
work for two weeks.
So it's like as long as I can pay my rent,
like that's...
You know, I would like everyone
to walk out with money personally.
- I'm trying to pay for a wedding
with the smartest guy I ever met.
- Oh, I love it. Yeah.
- Kind of like the life I live right now.
Like it's fun as fuck.
Like I do cool shit, but
this last year or so,
like I've been getting to like NFD.
I don't wanna sound cringe,
but like I feel like getting
like financial freedom
and like getting rich is way like easier.
I'm trying to make a lot of money.
- I think like the only
per that I would say
like is kind of separate
from the group is Number Two.
Just because when we were all
talking about our interests
and why we wanna like take home the money,
they seemed a little more like
money centric for themselves.
- I don't know, are we on the same page
about maybe creating like
a spending amount per day?
- I think we really have to do that
if we feel like the number
is dropping too fast.
- Yeah, here's my thing.
I think it might be smarter
to make an individual spending limit
for the whole time total.
- True. 'Cause then it's gonna be like,
well, you know, like,
for the last two days you spent this much
and I've only spent-
- Oh, yeah.
- And you might feel pressured
too Spence since you have it.
- Exactly, but if we have
like a set amount between now
and when we get out,
then we could budget and
strategize for ourselves.
- I like that.
- Yeah. That sounds good.
(All cheering)
- Guys, we have break time like prisoners.
(All laughing)
(group chattering)
- Now that we know, next time we-
- Hold on, I'm putting on hand sanitizer.
- Thank you.
- Vaping is the one
thing I look forward to.
Me waiting hours to vape, it's crazy.
Y'all so light-headed.
I'm only gonna hit it, what, twice a day.
So it should last me, I think.
- How much was that? I'm curious.
- 2,000.
(All laughing)
Chill, chill, chill, 2,000.
Like I'm really addicted to vaping.
Like I'm trying to like be
cognizant of like, you know,
if I'm feeling a little bit cranky
and I don't want it to affect
the way I interact with people.
- Does everyone know what MREs
are? It's meals ready to eat.
It comes with its own
like self heating thing
and then we'll each have
like one full 1,200 calorie meal a day.
- Honestly, really spicy, good job.
- The idea for MREs,
that would be probably the
most bang for your buck
and the most calories.
My strategy is to just keep being useful.
The MREs seem to have gone over very well.
So holding onto that common sense.
- What?
- Oh.
- Already?
- Elimination.
- What is this?
- Message.
- [Rekstizzy] No way. There
will be elimination today.
- You must vote.
No side bets allowed.
If there is a tie, there
will be a tap breaker.
So there's none of this
like, "Oh, let's be kumbaya."
It's like get rid of someone.
- Okay.
- I'm honestly not prepared
for any game changes or twists.
This is a very high, intense,
and stressful situation.
Handling it is...
It's very difficult when you're
actually inside of a game.
- Oh, they killing us off, Jesus.
- Oh, the flood is about
to start pouring, huh?
- By day five is gonna be
too people just (indistinct)
- This is one of those
things where it's gonna test
that whole concept of everyone being nice.
And it's nice that everyone is being nice,
but now it's time to make a decision.
- Love you all.
- This has been great, honestly.
- Okay. Have you guys-
(All laughing)
My first instinct was like,
now I'm gonna go to my room,
cry about this whole thing.
- I feel like genuinely, like
no matter what happens today,
I really don't think anyone's
gonna have hard feelings
because it literally is a
game and everyone has feelings
and everyone's in this for
like really fair reasons.
- I will say. No matter
who gets kicked off,
the exposure we'll get from
this will help everyone.
- [Chance} I mean, I want the money,
but I understand what you're saying.
I get what you're saying.
- A consolation prize at least, you know,
your pretty face has been
on screen for this long.
- I get what you're saying,
but yeah, I need the money.
On the first day, V was kind
of getting under my skin
and I feel like she's at the
top of my list right now.
- I hope I can make alliances
with Sam, Chantel, AJ,
and Chance.
- I was like, okay,
this is something that's like a weakness.
And if this person doesn't fix this
or like try to make adjustments,
they might be someone that
people would consider.
- [Chantel] It sounds like vocalized it.
- It was adjusted.
And now this person is like
being a little bit more engaged.
But it sounds like to think about.
I was like, okay,
hearing those kind of things
make people change a reason.
- So try to end with something else,
so they don't know we're talking.
- Oh, yeah. I got you. I got you.
- I feel right now I'm
connecting with Chan for sure.
But I do think that she might
be a threat to the group
if she make a flip and
take the money for herself.
- My thoughts were, 'cause Chan
was saying we should do two,
then Four and I said...
I was like, "I don't have
enough way to move the house."
Like let's just not even
try to do any of that.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I've been really gungho
on aligning with Chance.
I think that him and I will just...
I think we'll tear up the game, I just do.
Just in case if it come down to two,
like how do you feel about that?
- It's me and you.
- Okay, cool. Cool. Okay.
- Okay.
- Great.
- Most of us are united in four.
- Have you talked about it with anyone?
- Yeah.
- You have?
- But like I fuck with you guys heavy,
you know what I'm saying?
Glasses crew.
(indistinct)
- I want as many people to
walk out this as possible,
but I also wanna take out
people who might not be
in that (indistinct)
- Yeah.
- I haven't been talking to anyone today
about aligning with them.
I haven't had any secret
side conversations.
If anyone's targeting me,
I think it's probably Rek
because I think he knows that of anyone,
he's irritating me the most.
And I think preemptively,
he wants to fight back against that.
- How are you doing?
- I'm all right.
I'm nervous about
elimination like everyone.
- You have like any idea?
- I really don't,
because here's the thing,
I feel like we all know how to
put up that facade of like...
I can't get as accurate a gauge
on like people's impressions of me
because I grew up looking
like this in Nebraska
when everyone hated whatever
this actress, serial is,
whatever personality was.
So I'm used to people just
kind of assuming I'm a bitch
upon meeting me.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- Oo-oh.
- Curfew warning.
- We have to go like right now?
- I'm going to go to my room.
- Bring it in. Bring it in.
- Oh, he got his arms. Come on, man.
- Oh, we got Rek's arms, bro
- Rope brigade, bro.
- Rope brigade.
(All laughing)
- Feels good, feels bad.
- Are you okay?
- Yesterday night, I was a
little bit more sure of myself,
but now, you know, it could be me.
- Holy shit.
Yo, this is not fun.
In regards to my position,
I think I'm most concerned
because I don't know what position I'm in.
That's the downside of
a hanging out so much.
I don't really know where I
run on other people's lists.
I don't know if I'm at the top.
I don't know if I'm in the middle.
So I'm kind of concerned
that I might be at the bottom
for some people and I don't want that.
(monitor beeping)
- [Announcer] Next time on Money Game.
- I intend to eliminate Rek tonight.
- I wouldn't miss the snoring personally.
I don't know how the game
is gonna shift on us.
- In this game, if we're
forced to vote each other out,
there has to be some sort of deception.
(Chance sobbing)
- When is the shoe going to drop?
- Today, you can vote
twice for the same person.
- Holy shit.